all right Diamond yes diamond where are
you from originally where'd you grow up
um I grew up in Compton
Compton and tell me about your family uh
okay so my family okay my granny my
grandma was born in Georgia Louisiana so
that's why I had this country accent
um you know pretty much I grew up at
Compton with my family mainly with me
and my mom at first and my dad didn't
I feel like my life changed once my
parents got a divorce and I was like I
would say like I was six or seven at
that time so once my parents got
divorced my mom she took me away from my
dad
because at that time she felt like
whatever he was doing wasn't enough
maybe but also he's a gang member too so
she was like well if you're not gonna
leave the streets alone and raise your
kid then I'ma just take my kid and raise
her myself
so you know she ended up taking me away
from my dad she kept me away from my dad
for a while
and
I feel like how that reflected on me
it's probably why I went down the path I
went down but it ain't nobody fault but
mine but mainly when my parents
separated
I kind of I kind of felt bad every
Father's Day and stuff like that I
didn't have a father to come to I had a
mom I didn't know if my parents broke up
because of me or not so you know I I
wanted to depression right there
I started to be shy I was scared to make
any friends I was scared
I don't know I was scared of a lot to be
honest once I lost my parents and that
relationship that they had it kind of
made me more distance from the world
so you know um after that
I pretty much just kept going to school
and [ __ ] like that you finished high
school huh did you finish High School
yes I did I graduated from Centennial
High School
um it was you know Centennial high
schools in Compton and it's like um
there's a whole bunch of [ __ ] going on
in that school
it's mainly gangs and stuff at that
school so when I started going to
Centennial
that kind of messed me up also because I
ended up starting to go to jail I
started going to juvenile hall
so it's a high school for troubled kids
no no no it's a high school but it's
full of troubled kids that's what I mean
you feel me the kids there they go there
to smoke weed they sell we don't care
because they sell pills they sell
whatever they you know they sell a lot
of the kids they're gang banging stuff
and obviously I wasn't raised out there
like I was raised out there but then
when my mom got divorced with my my dad
we ended up going to Oregon
Daytona Beach Florida she kind of moved
me around wherever she could get low
income or Section 8 housing you feel me
so when I went to this school it was
kind of like
paranoid I got bullied a lot
I fell out of place a lot
so I kind of felt like when I was going
back and forth to the halls I was doing
a lot of bad stuff to go back to Joe
because I didn't have nobody to take
care of me both my parents at that time
was in jail my mom and my dad they got
criminal records and my granny was the
only person I could take care of me and
she's around the corner getting high and
stuff like that you know which is not
her fault a lot of people get hooked on
drugs and stuff like that
but I kind of took it in at 14 15 16 I
started making money I started coming
out you know making money
I didn't look to do this stuff a lot of
men came up to me because I had a very
thick body at that time
so a lot of them they're like oh she
looks like she's 20 or something like
that just how my body type was but
really I was 16 when I first started
doing this
um one guy had came up to me I used to
stay on Sports and Banker I was just
walking but you know that's not too far
from Figaro so they obviously think that
oh she might be a working girl too a lot
of men would come up and offer me a
hundred dollars and stuff just you know
because they want a sexual acts from me
and stuff like that
and at that time I was very vulnerable I
didn't have nobody but a house full of
people that's doing drugs and stuff
so I'm like I need to make some money to
support myself so I could eat have
somewhere to lay my head buy shoes buy
clothes
you know but I also school work too that
these people are supposed to be helping
me with but my family is just all over
the place right now
so I ended up doing that
then I I kind of I was also I was
boosting I was doing a whole bunch of
other stuff than just you know
making some money on the street
and um I ended up meeting my baby daddy
at 16.
the worst mistake I'm in my life let's
just say that I met him young at 16 he
was eight years older than me so he was
like 27 maybe 26 at that time
um
and when I met him he was against the
homie making money things so instead I
just started boosting you know stealing
clothes to make money
um stealing hair products stealing
anything I could still
to um make a living and [ __ ]
and um I ended up getting pregnant when
I was 17. but at the time of 16 and 17
with him I was in and out of jail
I got back out when I was like 17.
and when I I actually had a when I was
17
I came home I came home in September
then I got pregnant in October then I I
didn't have my baby until after I was 18
my birthday is March 15 2002 so I'm 20
years old
and I had my son at 18 and my son is now
two years old but I'm no longer with his
dad no more and
once a life is there that's how I kind
of got back into this [ __ ]
because I'm like this man is not doing
nothing but abusing me beating on me and
stuff like that
and not benefiting me in any type of way
and I need to provide for my kids so
I understand this might not be the
safest thing and it's not the safest
thing but like this is how I make my
income are you raising your child yeah
I'm still raising my child yes I have my
child except I don't be my child he's
not around this my mom takes care of him
you know are you staying in an apartment
are you at motels no it's an apartment
yeah I have my own apartment before this
but I was staying in real world and a
lot of the people over there is not that
friendly so uh African-American female
moving into this [ __ ] so as soon as I
moved in over there then people did they
best to try to get me kicked out of
there I don't play loud music I don't
have parties I believe in a husband
myself okay with my kid so they were
trying to make it seem like you know
they were reporting me for false stuff
that there's no reason for me to get
reported had the landlord coming to my
house and all that
but um are you working with the pimp now
currently you said well are you working
with the pimp oh no no I don't have a
payment you buy yourself yes
I wrote by myself because
that's a little too much going on I
advocate that too I don't have no time
for a Pimp especially if I don't have no
time for his dad you feel me is I'm very
independent over here
you leave the child with the mom yeah
you go work yeah that's why that's why I
come out in the daytime because she
works at nighttime so I could be it with
my son at night time
because my son is he not he's not like a
bad baby he's very sweet he's very chill
he he's my world right there but sooner
or later I am going to get out this game
and
I'm thinking about going back to college
doing something productive with myself
what would you like to do
to be honest I want to do I need to go
cab I really wanted to be a nurse
but it's too much to be in there
sometimes so I'm trying to look around
to see what I really want I don't know
if I want to open up my own business and
do hair and stuff
I have to figure that out but I just
know for a fact that when I do figure it
out I'm going back to school to go get
an actual job instead of having to do
this because I'm not
this is not what I plan
to have going on when I'm 25. I'm not
going to be out here doing this are you
saving money yeah I saved my money I put
it into my bank account good for you
yeah so but I like I told him I told him
I said I spend money too for like my
priorities and stuff like food clothes
whatever you use drugs oh yeah I only
smoke that's it smoke weed
I don't do nothing else I don't drink I
just always like read my parents are
weed head so that's why I get it from
and how do you
how does this affect you emotionally
doing this
um does it get to you it does because I
uh when I was when I was growing up I I
always seen a lot of girls on fig and I
always would say that I wouldn't be one
of them
and I ain't even gonna I used to down
talk a lot of females
you saw them growing up when you were
young
yeah I have aunties that's tough they
were very like this you feel me and
that's kind of how I also got into the
game too just my auntie they're fast as
[ __ ] no disrespect aunties but they
don't they they put me at 16 years old
they trying to put me on sites with
grown men and stuff that's a bad
influence already so that's exactly why
I wouldn't have none of the people
around my kid because just saying that
my own aunties knew that I was 16 and I
was very vulnerable the fact that they
helped me get on these sites POF in all
these dating sites that I shouldn't have
been on I'm 16 years old thinking that
this is okay and all this and I'm not
saying that these men are perverse I'm
16 and they're grown men and they're
asking me for these services so at 16 I
didn't like doing it so that's why I got
an arrest [ __ ] with my baby daddy at
that time but at 18 I felt more better
doing it because I'm grown now and I
feel like nobody's taking advantage of
me now but it's still a scary feeling
that I have out here because we get
kidnapped sometimes you can get robbed
sometimes you could get raped sometimes
you know so you have to be very very
smart on who you get in the car with or
who you bring to your house or wherever
you lay your head at because a lot of
these men out here are not even
they're serial killers out here like on
Vegas people that pick up the girls and
they drop the bodies off and they don't
find the bodies into the morning like
and um I'm not trying to bring up my
friend but you know essence
Essence ended up getting killed on fake
so I feel like when she ended up getting
killed on fig
they turned the tables for a lot of
girls they're like you know what hell no
I'm gonna find a job I'm gonna go to the
strip club like I've been looking for a
strip club a lot of girls want to go to
the strip club because we feel like it's
safer because
because it's too dangerous out here you
got to worry about gang bangers and
pimps trying to chase you down and then
some of these girls that do pay pimps
they end up getting killed because
that pimp is like oh if you leave me
I'ma kill you you know or or like they
get magic because they want to be with
another pimp or something like that
it is sad as hell to say that you you
like doing what you're doing but at the
end of the day it's scary for us
and a lot of girls I'm starting to see
now to be honest a lot of the girls are
going to stop doing this because Essence
kind of prove a point to everybody
she was with a dude a pimp that ended up
getting her killed in a car like that's
too much going on you know I feel like
it's better for us to work at a strip
club
you can still make your money under the
table in the strip club that's that's
what they got private rooms for so
that's why I'm looking for a strip club
right now and they accept me but
I'm not gonna just go apply for a strip
club and I don't have no experience so
right now I'm trying to stack my money
up and go to poll classes go to strip
classes so when I do go out to get
accepted
what was the best example of a loving
relationship you saw as a young girl
your mom and dad
probably not um
damn uh but the best relationship oh I'd
like to say my grandparents yeah yeah
both sides my grandparents they always
stay married you know they both my
grandparents they have high school
sweethearts you feel me back then there
was no social media so they grew all
together so I really look up to my
grandparents relationship and hopefully
find out hopefully I find somebody in
the future that could be loyal and
trustworthy and all that it's kind of
hard to trust people in this world
because of social media now all this
other stuff you know that the the man
has access to nowadays
do you regret getting into this in the
first place
I like to say yes and no it's only
because like
the fact that I'm in this is mainly my
king that's the no part it's mainly my
son I can tell that I'm gonna get out
this game sooner or later because I put
my cable for anything and
I would love to I would love to do this
if I didn't have a kid at all
you know it hurts me sometimes because
it's like I'm a mother but a lot of
people don't discredit me for it because
at the end of the day I'm taking care of
my kids whatever I do I hear is always
protected kind of moan all the time no
matter how much a minute try to pay me
I'm not ever going
I'm not ever gonna have sex without a
condom if they try if they say I'll give
you a thousand dollars it's not worth it
it's not worth it one time losing your
life for HIV and AIDS just understand
that as women you even if you are here
putting a price on it at least have some
self-respect and some more is about
yourself so you can know that okay I
made my money the good way I didn't make
my money the nasty where I had to this
man discredited me or took something I I
don't allow people to do you're gonna
feel used and abused so it's better to
come off you know have some more is
about yourself so at the end of the day
and pretty much you know like that's how
I think about it is like I have mores
for myself I know that I'm providing for
my kid so when people judge me and they
record me and stuff like that I don't
even pay no attention because it's like
I'm not gonna let my kid starve I'm not
gonna be a parent that's just gonna sit
on her ass and I make no money
I have to get up every day to come out
here to make some money but I always do
you typically work
well I call that a work because you know
we do eight hours a day
but your days or nights or both I'll
I'll do both depending on how slow it is
in the daytime and how slow it is a
night
you think you've changed your views on
men from doing this kind of work
um do you see men differently because
you've been doing this yes I'm gonna be
honest with you I see myself differently
because now it's like no man can speak
to me without giving me no money that's
a problem because I want to be able to
be that girl I'll make my money here and
just be a regular girl like like that's
how I am I feel like I'm an undercover
girl Loki because I go out there and the
people that know me that work out there
they know me but other than that like
when I go outside I'm just presentable
classy you know I like to hide this life
you know like how Superman has
you know he has Clark Kent and he's
Superman that's how I kind of look at it
like women I'm Wonder Woman out there
and they're seeing on Diana on the other
side
but yeah uh I say it makes me look at me
differently because I like okay y'all I
got money for me
I don't talk to men like how I used to
like where make I get a free
conversation out of you I'll be like you
have to give me some money and able to
talk to me and I don't like that at all
because I like I like being
I like being regular too somebody that
you could talk to like a regular human
being not somebody that just wants some
money
I wish I could change my mindset about
that and I'm still working on it to try
to do better and [ __ ] but it's hard for
me have you been in love before in love
I've been in love with my baby daddy um
the first two years we was together
until like after we had my son I had to
realize that
you won't love it has to be a genuine
love it's not gonna be a toxic love
you know I was in an abusive
relationship
my baby daddy kind of wanted to control
over everything my clothes all my stuff
um taking my birth certificate my social
taking stuff for me to give me to stay
with the man when I didn't want to stay
with him he'll put his hands on me you
know beat me up kick me spit on me and
all that like
and that's exactly why he ain't got [ __ ]
right now
and I guarantee you he learned his
lesson too very clear because now he
tries to get me back in all type of way
because you understand that you had a
very beautiful woman that you
disrespecting entirely so at the end of
the day that's his loss I met him when I
was 16. I'm 20 now
I don't ever plan on giving that man a
chance to no I'm never gonna be with
that man again that's just like my
answer on that
do you get lonely are you lonely
no no I'm not lonely when I ever since I
had my kid that's what gave me the
spirit to leave him because if I would
have left him before I would have felt
lonely but the fact that I had a kid was
like
it filled my void all I care about is my
case I would never feel lonely like
mama my mom will tell you like when my
mom left my dad she raised me she never
had sex with nobody else she never
raised nobody else she didn't she didn't
care about nobody else but me and my mom
is still like my mom lost her virginity
to that man when he was 16. that's the
only person she slept with my mama has
to slept with no man and is not going to
sleep with no man until she passes away
she's kind of like how you would say
Queen Elizabeth she feels like she wants
a diversion even though she had sex
already she's not looking for nobody
else that's why I'm very independent in
my own matter because my mom sleeps with
herself and she's 40 years old she's
been doing this ever since I was a kid
and if that woman has enough power to
keep her legs closed and make her money
and say that you can sleep by yourself
you don't have to depend on the man
all I care about is myself and
supporting my kid you know I'm not
really looking for no man no love
interest
do you believe in karma
yes I do I'm um
most person I believe is the karma man
that's why I carry myself differently I
don't do people fight I never robbed
from nobody like I tell people the only
place I stole from is a store but I
never stole from a human being a friend
a relative not even a person I want to
date you know I'm not no Thief so how I
move in life is how I want God to um
you know
give me my blessings in so I don't look
for no Karma I don't do nothing fast so
I won't get no Karma
so tell me about hiding money
okay so like hiding money first or
hiding money so you don't get robbed
right yeah so but I had my money is
always going to be I always wear wigs
it's always good to wear a wig you know
and a wig cap under because then
they put a wig off they ain't gonna see
nothing under that wig cap and the wig
cap is always gonna make sure that it's
stuck on your head you put it just under
the wig your money's gonna be able to
fall out it's so loose and another good
place is also our Hills uh I go to
Exotic spot LA and the new family he
knows everything we do so he pretty much
he has pockets in our heels that you can
see that blends in so well that only we
know that it's a zipper there and you
can put all your money in there because
usually they like to go for purses they
like to go for jackets Pockets titties
you know your area back there in front
there a lot of the days I already know
where we'll be putting our money at so
it's better to put it under a wig cap
they don't everything wig cap or
stripper heels because whenever I used
to get Robbins it's either my boob it's
either in my [ __ ] or it's over here
you're revealing all your secrets though
yeah
but I'm letting anybody know that's
where you put it at
Diamond what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
most important lesson I learned in my
life is just a
um
I really like to say independent
I learned a lot from independent I
learned a lot from it's so many life
lessons I learned it's so hard to just
put it on one
because I learned a lot growing up in
the halls and being humble as [ __ ]
my lesson is just always it's just treat
everybody how you want to be treated
um my also lesson is just like
well my lesson for everybody is it's
like no matter how people judge you and
stuff like that just stay true to
yourself try to do the right thing you
know
um I learned how to watch my
surroundings how to um
save a lot of money too because before I
was Reckless spending a lot of money on
weed like 200 300 on weed um
I learned my lesson and I'm like you
know what if I save up a lot of money
like I have a piggy bank so I'll put 100
in my piggy bank every day
so I learned lessons and savings and
some more stuff
I like to say I learned a lot of lessons
that's hard for me to say good for you
all right Diamond thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you wish you
the best of luck right there thank you
stay safe